what are your thoughts on looting as a
method of hastening change
i'm mainly against it um
are you ever for it no not i can think
of
uh you're referring i assume among other
things to the book that's just been
published in america
in defense of looting 2016 that came out
you know
did it really gosh that was actually
really really interesting
so the it's had its moment now that book
hasn't it
she is so much more insightful than you
her ability to see what's going on in
the future is
that much greater than yours yeah and so
vikki osterweil for anyone who doesn't
know what it is i've got a little
a little breakdown here and then i'll
get your opinions on it um
so npr summarizes the book as an
argument that quote
looting is a powerful tool to bring
about real lasting change in society end
quote osterwile's argument is simple
the so-called united states was founded
in quote
cis hetero patriarchal racial capitalist
violence
that violence produced our current
system particularly its property
relations and
looting is a remedy for that sickness
looting rejects the legitimacy of
ownership rights
and property the moral injunction to
work for a living in the justice of law
and order
ownership of things not just people is
innately structurally white supremacist
looting is good she says because it
exposes a deep truth about the great
american confidence game which is that
without
quote without police and without state
oppression we can have things for free
she came to this conclusion six years
ago
and in her book which is written in love
and solidarity with loot is the world
over
well the obvious question is where does
she live
the only thing you need to know do you
know that at the front of the book
they have the classic um this is
copyrighted by whatever publishing
i know because a colleague of mine a
spectator wrote to her publishers the
other day
saying we are publishing our own edition
of this
uh looting her book you were just
looting her book
and the publishers didn't seem to be up
for that you'd be amazed to hear
well i mean i just said look if you see
it in the bookshop take it it's yours
all properties theft why not
turns out actually nobody wants to steal
her book certainly not if it's filled
with stuff like you just read
um these people i mean they're so
reprehensible on so many levels i mean
first of all by the way
um how ignorant can somebody be
i mean how ignorant do you have to be to
make that claim about the foundation of
american society
and i suspect like a number of authors
of the american far left she's never
been
anywhere else in the world in her life i
just strongly suspect that
um if if she can send me photos of
herself in sub-saharan africa
north africa across a lot of the middle
east and the far east and things i i
could be persuaded
but i would suspect that she's been
brought up in america hasn't traveled
very much further and has simply been
indoctrinated in this now completely
boring and predictable way
where all you need to do is throw out
this same word salad about
heteronormativity and
uh and indigenous people and all this
sort of thing and before you know it
you've got a
not very well selling book that you
can't even get stolen
but the the
do you remember the sargon of akkad
thing that he got really really in
trouble for
where he said i wouldn't even rape you
that was his
thing to the politician i can't remember
the lady's name and that was what got
him in trouble
this is a book so bad you wouldn't even
steal it
it can't be so i mean if anyone can show
me an example of it being stolen but
you know um it's it's also i mean
it's it's it's amazing we're in this era
and that people are
talking and thinking like this i i
simply think it's
she is a product of
capitalism at this particular stage
where um she doesn't know very much she
hasn't been very
far in the world she's not been educated
well
she's not seen anything of the world she
doesn't know anything about life she
doesn't know how life is normally
run and all of that is playing out on
the streets of various american cities
at the moment primarily portland oregon
uh but there are a lot of people in this
strange
position i i have a lot of friends in
america who tell me that this
is very common this sort of thing among
their children and grandchildren they
say that they
they they genuinely think like this uh
woman that
uh that their country is uniquely bad
and these people just don't know
anything they just don't know anything
they don't know anything about history
they don't know anything about geography
they don't know anything about the world
and i'm i'm very uninterested in the
thoughts
of these intensely parochial so-called
internationalists
uh because that's what they are i mean
they just they have never seen
the consequences of their own thought
they they
the idea that you take away the police
and everything will be was it free i
think she said
yeah yeah well you also will get a
massive upsurge in rape
murder disproportionately in minority
communities as well yeah and um and then
what are you going to blame it on
uh maybe the period when we still had
police and there's a lingaro there's a
lingering overness that makes people do
that for a time
i mean this is juvenile thinking this is
it's not juveniles it's wicked and
juvenile thinking
um again i don't think very many people
believe it
and i think that this is there is an
argument it's a bleak argument
that people like her simply have to see
this tested
close up at some point did we not see
this with chas chop
was that not a perfect microcosm for
this that you could absolutely
you can have idiocy masquerading
as moral virtue
within a few there are certain there are
certain very very pertinent
the chas chad was a very
uh good example of it there are lots of
individuals who
who demonstrate it do you remember that
big story i think it was in the
new york times when it was still a
newspaper uh which
uh where there was a description of a
couple an american couple again
something like oregon no
that could be another couple this couple
didn't have guns as far as in fact
they're very anti-gun
they were very pro-peace though and they
feared that the world
uh was lacking in love and they just
needed to give a bit more love to the
world
and you can see how this ends already
can't you uh they decided to go on a
cycling holiday and sort of spread
spread well something or other
and uh then they ended up just getting
killed by a jihadi cell in like
tajikistan
and they did a blog of their stops in
various places in the far east and the
near east there's cycling i think a lot
of tandem even
and then they just yeah you know one day
they you know it's all and this all the
stuff is like we just you know you think
the world just needs more love and
and more tandem holidays they've got
rose petals they've got a basket of rose
petals in front
and then yeah and and this this a couple
of guys a couple of jihadis
saw them one day and just you know on
the flukes i couldn't believe their luck
clearly and just
just took them out so
human naivety is very familiar and
one has to be careful not to laugh too
much of the people who express it but
it's a very
it's a very common thing uh to be
totally naive about the nature of the
world
ordinarily you get over it when you're
very young
unfortunately in america in particular
we have uh
a generation of juveniles who are
growing up and
still juvenile and who actually believe
these things
who actually believe that you know life
is really
quite straightforward you know if you
just don't have the police and you just
like defund the police and you don't
have
don't have the patriarchal
cis-heteronormative state then
then what i mean by the way did you see
somebody did a video the other day from
portland oregon of one of these parks
where they've really done their best you
know
uh uh the protesters and it's just it
really does look like the apocalyptic
wasteland they deserved
just covered in piss and just people
just
lying zonked out on whatever illegal or
legal drugs they've been able to get and
everyone just looks like they've pissed
themselves and they've
taken they've taken i'm not everyone
wearing a trench coat that's what i
imagine
lots of friends they're all wearing
someone else's trench coat yeah and yeah
and and the and they've got all the
statues are down of course the whole
place is covered in plinths
uh uh beautiful plinths everywhere uh no
but
and all the plinths are covered in blm
graffiti and [ __ ] the state and
police of this and that's what these
people inherit and they deserve to
inherited
a urine stenched graffitied wasteland
in which just zombies lie around until
they die
i really want to just put that as the
trailer that's just
the episode that's right that's you know
that
this is what they deserve this is what
they deserve this is the final endpoint
of their self
i can't believe that there are actually
adults talking about
this or stuff and the new york times and
the new you know
the npr and things taking these
discussions seriously
we we've done the experiment many times
before in human history of what happens
when you have
a total breakdown of law and order and
it always comes out looking
exactly like
you